Europe's teachers are high on the agenda
when EU education ministers meet in
Brussels this week The ministers want to
share information about some of the
practical methods they're using to
improve the teaching profession teacher
quality is one of the most important
factors influencing student achievement
and plays a pivotal role in the life and
employment prospects of young Europeans
The ministers will also look at ways to
improve access to higher education for
students from disadvantaged backgrounds
young people too will be the focus when
ministers responsible for youth policy
meet to debate quality employment and
its contribution to their development
well-being and social inclusion culture
ministers for their part is set to
designate arthas in denmark and pathos
in Cyprus as European capitals of
culture for 2017 valletta in Malta is
the candidate for 2018 meanwhile sports
ministers are set to name an EU
representative to the world anti-doping
agency as part of efforts to combat
doping in sport doping is becoming
increasingly sophisticated and is
threatening the integrity of sport elite
athletes are often wrong model for young
people and sport more generally brings
important social economic and health
benefits to society the head of the u.s.
Doping agency will join the ministers to
debate the role of state authorities in
fighting the use of
performance-enhancing drugs the council
will also address match-fixing and moves
to allow the European Commission to take
part in negotiations on an international
convention on the manipulation of sports
results